this is complex food and a lot could go
wrong but so far
Omar's as cool as a cucumber in his
gazpacho this place are immaculate I
mean we've just started service and
we're any half there in two but compose
yeah daddy goes for the first looking
absolutely spotless but will his
unorthodox dishes be too experimental
for my Dyna Stace a carpaccio pig's
Trotter yes it's amazing ladies are
incredible
never thought I'd sorry it's true
customers are loving the food and it's
not exactly what they expected listen
the atmosphere yo anyone think there's
music playing the background the music
are the customers they're happy
even the cockscomb will also is going
down well but each dish must be made to
order and he's put impression on the
kitchen got a girl
the rice is popular - I know yeah it's
selling quite a lot and the cockscomb I
think challenge they can sometimes so
well
it's a rare ingredient they're very
ready see the kitchen sends out the last
cockscomb below so that's edible right
it is really suckling really tasty and
really nice in but Roberto fails to
notice the happy diners neighbor has yet
to be fair to me I think it's just been
a a small mixer my main course hasn't
arrived yet
cousins happy very happy yeah how many
sailors got left to go miss it's no more
hot food no
finally Roberto spots the problem oh
[ __ ]
there's no way Omar can get this out
quickly
wait a pat-down everyone's already
finished this sorry about what happened
I did a mistake because of the Russian
everything came at once but yeah the
most important thing is to the food
correctly even though they need to wait
a couple of minutes extra fine it's not
until dessert start to leave the kitchen
that the delayed milazzo is sent miss
how you eat the less power
was it worth the wait time so you worked
the way but just to show you a tough job
oh you guys did finish yours but my
journey lends out it does food fantastic
our Piratas near fortress performance
has been down to omars shares skill and
passion he's pulled off the remarkable
making humble and unappealing
ingredients taste like a million dollars
this detail is a piece of art on a plane
it looks beautiful it tastes beautiful
I think the food here is absolutely
incredible some things that I never
would have thought of eating but
actually worked really really well
tough challenge my diners are over the
moon
well done wait for the final yes yeah
no what do you know are you we are yes I
love that confidence it's always like
you've won the World Cup good job
excellent